I think you were on another film show
and the guy said man I fall in love with
my lead actress every time I forget what
it was but he said like for that movie
you become so engrossed and you fall in
love with those characters yeah once
it's done you're just you're on to the
next thing exactly exactly back to
normal life we have to say goodbye it's
done and I think the most for me the big
revelation was the male lead of the film
dad which is played by Matt Cooper who
is the father of the lead actress of
being zone and so basically I had a hard
time finding my dad my dad character so
so during these two days I couldn't find
anyone who was dad so I was like whom
I'm gonna be I'm gonna have to bring
some other people so I did another
afternoon of additions for dad at UCLA
on campus and so we had like 30 other
people coming I was like and it was
still not finding the right dad and then
came this guy Matt Cooper this a great
actor and who just brought this
humanistic side of dad because daddy in
my script was too much of a bad guy I
kind of nut clichy because and they want
him to be cliche but I mean it was
thrilled bad guy and when Matt came in
the audition he brought that human side
of that and it was like how he is making
these bad choices but he has good
intentions and that's something I didn't
see in my own script and when Matt came
in and brought this on table I was like
this is perfect this is who that is so I
hired him right away and was happy where
are you posting these casting notices we
used a few we used
la casting the website la casting which
as these I mean everybody's in on LA
casting which is great so it's perfect
we had huge huge responses and and all
these people were I wanted these people
to I was not going to look for what
they've been doing in the past I'm not
this kind of guy who look in the back of
the resume I'm all I'm more looking in
front of the resume and what they're
doing actually in front of me and and
that's why I I knew that I wanted to
have people who are fresh in a way and
would have not been on the circuit of
indie films too much I wanted them to be
fresh and creative and and try some
stuff on said so so that's why most of
them had not so many credits I mean some
of them had some good Kraze but none of
them had big credits and that was the
great thing because they were fresh that
these new faces they were not a famous
and and for me that was the most three
part of it
you